An einem nebligen Morgen zeigen sich die
Stars des Berliner Zoos in ihrem Gehege:
Meng Yuan und Meng Xiang,
Spitznamen: Pit und Paule.
Sie sind die ersten Pandas, die
jemals in Deutschland geboren wurden.
Tierpfleger Corvin Schmohl kümmert
sich seit ihrer Geburt um die beiden
und hat ihre Entwicklung in den vergangenen
zehn Monaten aufmerksam verfolgt.
Ja, wir haben hier sehr viele lustige
Situationen mit den beiden Kleinen.
Gerade momentan ist so …
ja, das Hauptthema,
die beiden dort
oben wieder runterzubekommen.
Weil, wenn die da am Schlafen sind,
ist es relativ schwierig.
Da sie noch nicht so
gut auf ihre Namen hören,
müssen wir halt probieren,
die so ’n bisschen zu motivieren
und so ’n bisschen runterzulocken.
Das sieht von außen
immer sehr unterhaltsam aus,
denn die sind schon sehr stur.
Pit und Paule wurden
im August 2019 geboren.
Nach etwa drei Wochen bekamen sie
die typische schwarz-weiße Färbung.
Besonders viele Artgenossen haben sie nicht:
Weniger als 2.000 Große Pandas
leben schätzungsweise in freier Wildbahn,
etwa 600 gibt es in Gefangenschaft.
Die Nachzucht der Einzelgänger ist eine
komplizierte Angelegenheit.
Die Zucht beim Panda ist nicht so einfach.
Da gibt’s so ’ne kleine Besonderheit, nämlich:
Die weiblichen Tiere sind im ganzen Jahr nur
ungefähr drei Tage aufnahmefähig,
und das ist natürlich ’nen sehr,
sehr kurzer und begrenzter Zeitraum,
den wir natürlich zum einen
perfekt abpassen müssen.
Und da darf halt einfach nix schiefgehen,
weil ansonsten müssen wir
halt wieder ein Jahr warten,
bevor wir den nächsten
Anlauf starten können.
Die Pandas sind eine Leihgabe aus China.
Mutter Meng Meng und Vater Jiao Qing
kamen im Juli 2017 nach Berlin.
Schon zwei Jahre später
klappte es mit dem Nachwuchs.
Pandabären verbringen den
größten Teil des Tages mit Schlafen.
Corvin Schmohl präpariert
ein Stück Stoff mit Eukalyptus,
um Jiao Qing zum Spielen zu animieren.
Das scheint zu klappen
– zumindest für fünf Minuten.
Dann heißt es: Pause.
Der Bärenhunger ist trotzdem groß.
Für die Pandas importiert der
Berliner Zoo tonnenweise Bambus
aus Frankreich und den Niederlanden.
Wir brauchen hier sehr
große Mengen an Bambus,
denn das Männchen bekommt
täglich schon um die 40 Kilo Bambus
und die Meng Meng
auch momentan so 45 Kilo,
und das sind natürlich enorme Mengen, die
da über ’ne Woche zusammenkommen.
Und die beiden Kleinen fangen sich auch so
langsam an, dafür zu interessieren.
Also, sie knabbern schon mal
so ’n bisschen auf den Blättern drauf rum.
Bei den Besuchern des Berliner Zoos
sorgen die Pandas für Begeisterung
auch wenn es für Pit und Paule bald
schon wieder Zeit für ein Nickerchen ist.